Hey everyone I am Abbey Sharp welcome to another edition of Fertility Files here
at Abbey's Kitchen! Now, you may remember
that in some of my previous Fertility
Files videos we talked about my personal
struggle with infertility in trying to
get pregnant and that one of the major
issues that I had in my journey was that
my uterine lining just didn't thicken,
and that it was suggested that it was
possible that my long term use of the
birth control pill may have played a
role. I was on the pill for 14 years,
before which I had a totally normal
regular cycle but when I came off I just
never got a period. So based on your
overwhelming interest in this topic, I
wanted to dive deep into the research to
find out what the literature said about
the oral contraceptive use and long term
fertility. I also acknowledge that I am
NOT a doctor and I'm specifically not a
reproductive endocrinologist or a
gynecologist. So I am in no way giving
you any advice at all on your own use of
the birth control pill. I am however
trained and analyzing research, so what I
am planning to do today is to simply
regurgitate my findings as unbiased as I
possibly can and to bring you some
actual credible advice from some experts
in this unique field. So I'm going to be
joined by my reproductive
endocrinologist Dr. Tom Hannam from
Hannam Fertility Clinic in Toronto as
well as Mama Dr. Jones to get their take.
Now before we get into this of course I
want to remind you that the information
in this video is for educational and
entertaining purposes only and you
should always speak to your doctor about
your unique healthcare case.
Okay so let's kick things off by
answering an important introductory
question. How does the birth control pill
even work? Now the pill is an oral
contraceptive that contains synthetic
estrogen and progestin, similar to the
hormones that naturally occur in a
woman's body, in order to trick the body
into suppressing ovulation. This takes
place because the pituitary gland
produces follicle stimulating hormone,
which is FSH, which in turn
stimulates the production of estrogen
and progesterone which lastly encourages
ovulation.
Now the synthetic hormones make the
pituitary glands produce less FSH,
suppressing normal ovulation. The birth
control pill also does a couple other
things to prevent unwanted pregnancy. The
first is a thinning of the uterine
lining. Now a uterine lining of at least
8 millimeters in thickness is really
important for maintaining pregnancy as
that is the lining that the fertilized
embryo can nestle into for implantation.
So to help prevent this from happening,
the pill depletes glycogen stores to
thin out the lining. The pill also may
thicken cervical mucus to prevent the
sperm from reaching any of the eggs.
There's a lot going on in these teeny
tiny little pills. Now does the pill
affect future fertility?
If you speak to most doctors, most will
advise you that after a few cycles post
pill your body will return to its pre-pill state. In fact, a lot of the evidence
on contraceptive use and fertility is
actually quite reassuring. One study
found that 96.8% of
women got their period back within three
months after coming off the pill, and
another study found that after one year
of pill use 57% of women got
pregnant after three months and 81%
got pregnant after 12 months.
There was even a study suggesting that
the longer women were on the pill, up to
five years, the greater their chances of
conceiving. The rationale being that the
extended hormonal exposure may confer a
protective effect via minimization of
endometrial proliferation and menstrual
shedding, which would help prevent
endometriosis or endometrial dysfunction.
However, we do know that not all women
respond to medication the same and a few
studies, as well as a lot of anecdotal
experiences, have found that there can be
more significant delays in the return of
your period and ovulation which in turn
may impact fertility. Now research has
found that the pill may disrupt normal
menstrual function
but the length of this disruption is
really what's up for debate.
One study found major cycle disturbances
after discontinuing oral contraceptives,
including cycle length changes with more
than 35 days in the luteal phase or anovulatory cycles for up to nine
months after discontinuing the pill.
Another prospective study on over a
thousand women who discontinued the pill
because they wanted to conceive, found
that the percentage of women who had
given birth after a year post-pill was
about 32% for the pill 39%
percent for an IUD and 54% for
vaginal barrier methods. Interestingly,
while IUD users did fare better than the
pill users in the short-term, the
long-term use of the IUD seemed to
really impact fertility with only 28% of
women who had used the IUD for 78 months
or more getting pregnant and delivering
compared to 46% of short-term
users. Another study compared pill users
with non hormonal diaphragm users, and
found that after 12 months
70% of prior pill users had not yet
given birth
compared with 46% of women who
had used a diaphragm for contraception.
The difference between groups did seem
to disappear after about 42 months post
pill, but still three and a half years is
a long time when you're desperately
trying to conceive. Finally, another study
evaluating a variety of contraceptive
methods found that it took 25% of former
pill users more than 13 months to
conceive after coming off the pill
compared to 12% and 8.5% of women using
IUDs and diaphragms, respectively. So the
research in this area as you can see is
clearly a mixed bag with some studies
finding no major differences in
contraceptive rates between pill users
and non-pill users, and others uncovering
some sobering stats. It's very likely
that different women respond differently
to different drugs and there are a few
possible reasons why some women may
experience this fertility delay. Number
one, the pills impact on uterine lining.
First, let's revisit how the pill thins
the uterine lining. Now, because it's
ideal to have a thicker uterine lining
here, probably about eight to fourteen
millimeters when you're trying to
conceive, the birth control pill is
supposed to thin the uterine lining in
hopes of preventing an unwanted
pregnancy. The question, however, is how
long it takes for a woman's uterine
lining to begin to thicken again after
discontinuing the pill, and how would
this impact her future fertility?
Well, while research in this area is
definitely in its infancy,
one study conducted in 2012 found that
long-term birth control pill use, about
five years or more, can potentially limit
the growth of the endometrial lining aka
the uterine lining. The study looked at a
138 patients and
found that those who had a uterine
lining thickness of seven millimeters or
thicker had a mean use of the birth
control pill of 5.8 years.
While those who had a thickness less
than seven millimeters, had a mean use of
9.8t years. In other words,
the longer you're on the pill the
potentially thinner the lining. Next,
let's consider the pills impact on
cervical mucus. So another concern is the
fact that the pill thickens the cervical
mucus to prevent sperm from getting up
there. Now how long does this last after
discontinuing the pill? Unfortunately, not
a whole lot of research has been done on
this topic. However, one study claimed that
after discontinuation menstrual
biomarkers such as length, intensity,
mucus score, and ovulation, were disturbed
for about two cycles. After the two
cycles, the biomarkers researched seemed
to start to regulate themselves given
some time. Now the third, is the pills
impact on AMH levels. Now, it's very
common for women who are trying to
conceive to get their anti-mullerian
hormone levels, aka AMH, tested to get an
idea of their overall fertility status.
AMH is used to check a woman's ability
to produce eggs that can be then
fertilized for pregnancy, where a higher
AMH is related to better chances of
conception.
One study found that after nine weeks of
using oral contraceptives, AMH levels
decreased in all women tested. In another
study of 244 women that used oral
contraceptives, their AMH levels were 19% lower than women who didn't use
them.
Lastly, in another study, 228 women who
used the pill had AMH levels lower than
women who didn't use it by almost a
third. Having said that, there have also
been a number of studies that state the
complete opposite suggesting that the
pill did not have any effect on women's
AMH levels. Honestly, it's hard to say
whether or not oral contraceptives lower
AMH levels in all women or how long it
may take before they resume. But, it makes
sense to get tested a few months
following discontinuation of the pill to
get some accurate results. Now, finally, I
want to talk about the pills impact on
ovarian aging. Now, a lot of women who
struggle with fertility after being on
the pill are possibly diagnosed with
ovarian aging. Ovarian aging can make it
really difficult to conceive due to the
fact that the ovaries aren't receiving the
nutrients that they need to develop and
maintain a pregnancy.
These nutrients include coq10, vitamin E,
vitamin C, and selenium. In one study, it
was found that women who were on the
pill had lower levels of coq10 and
vitamin E, compared to women who were not on the pill. Another study found that the
pill may also deplete nutrient levels of
folic acid, vitamin b2, b6, b12, C, E,
magnesium, selenium, and zinc. And most of these are key players in reproductive
health. In fact, one study found that
low levels of coq10 is a common
association with infertility in women
due to low mitochondrial activity in the
ovarian oocytes. This can explain why
women experience delays in fertility
after being on the pill, without actually
having any pre-existing conditions.
I also want to briefly touch on other
female health implications of the birth
control pill. Now in over 54 epidemiological
studies, over a hundred and fifty
thousand women were studied as well as
the relationship between the birth
control pill and breast cancer. Now, women
who had taken oral contraceptives in the
past had a 7% increase in the
risk of breast cancer, while women who
were currently taking oral
contraceptives had a 24%
increased risk. Another study found that
women who had taken the pill for over
five years, had a 10% increased risk for
cervical cancer and any longer it was
about a 60% increased risk. One
possible explanation for these findings
is that the synthetic hormones found in
the pill might increase the growth of
these cancers by binding to their
estrogen and/or progesterone receptors.
Well, that's not all so great news. You
might be happy to know that other
research has found that women who had
taken the pill had a reduced risk of
endometrial cancer as the pills suppresses
endometrial cell growth. It may also help
reduce the risk of ovarian cancer by
decreasing the amount of ovulations a
woman experiences, which in turn,
decreases the exposure to naturally
occurring female hormones. But if the
pill isn't to blame for my infertility
then what exactly is? Now, there's no
denying that the hormones in the pill
may potentially impact short-term
fertility but there is also the
possibility that some women are
struggling with something else that was
sneakily present even before they
started the pill. It's very difficult to
link post-pill amenorrhea directly to
the pill always due to the fact that
about 1-2 women get diagnosed
with amenorrhea after coming off the pill
out of every hundred. So while the pill
may help regulate and manage PMS
symptoms, it doesn't "cure" any
pre-existing conditions if present. It
only covers them up. So commonly masked
conditions include PCOS, hypothalamic
amenorrhea, and thyroid issues. And when
masking a conditioned for a prolonged
period of time, it can make it even more
difficult to regain your period
or your fertility once you come off the
pill. So now that I have given you all
the research that I could find,
I want to loop in my reproductive
endocrinologist Dr. Tom Hannam from Hannam Clinic here in Toronto. Okay so first
question for you, in your clinical
experience does the long term use of the
birth control pill impact women's
chances of conception and if so in
your experience how does it do that?
- The good news is for most women using birth
control like birth
control pill, is not going to be
consequential to their future
fertility. So women are positioned to be
taking the pill, for example, comfortably.
For many women it actually makes for
easier cycles and confident that
their future selves will be able to
achieve pregnancy afterwards. It's not
true for everybody, but it is true for
most people.
- That is very
reassuring because, I mean, for a lot of
women the birth control pill or any kind
of contraceptive is so important in
their lifestyle so.
- Right? So maybe someone might have started it a long time ago, maybe as a teenager
because of pain, for example, or just trying to control regularity or of course for
birth control. So for a lot of women
they've actually been on it for many
years.
Interestingly during this time with covid
a lot of family doctor groups,
chat groups, are talking about how many
women are extending their pills. So
people who have been thinking about
trying to achieve pregnancy a lot of
people are putting  it off taking
the pill for a bit longer or keeping
their IUD in place for a little bit
longer. Just as they sort of watch and
figure out how everything's gonna settle
out. So I could imagine there are a
number of people who would be watching
your channel, both on the pill right now
and uncomfortable with the idea not wanting
to get pregnant in this moment, but very
much hoping to be getting pregnant soon.
Very interesting. So for
those women who may be affected by the
pill, what is going on there that
may be causing those issues.
So the way the pill was designed was to be an estrogen, like your natural estrogen
level, and naturally when your body
has lots of estrogen in the middle of
the cycle it doesn't stimulate any eggs to
grow. So the idea behind the pill is,
[inaudible]
thats how it works. The thing is that
the estrogen is not your natural estrogen,
of course.
It's called estrogen estradiol, it's a
synthetic estrogen and it actually works
differently for every woman,
everyone's body, and it works differently
for different parts of their body.
So, that's why, first of all, a lot of women
have to find the right pill for them
just to try to find the right dose that
works but that makes them feel kind of
normal. But even then, it's never exactly
normal. It's never exactly what it would
be naturally like to them with natural
estrogen levels. These estrogens actually,
interestingly, they work as positive
estrogens in some places and negative
estrogens in others. It's weird,
it's the way it binds to receptors.
So for many women, it will, for example, take away hot flashes if a woman had a really
naturally low estrogen level and takes
the pill, it should look better. That's a
good thing. It might help with bone density,
in similar ways. But at the lining of
the uterus, for many women it actually
acts as an anti-estrogen. So the
way she experiences that, is having very
light menses or no menses at all.
So a lot of people watching this will be able
to recognize that, they'll be like yeah
when they're taking the pill they will
have lighter menses than usual. That
actually can be, for some, that's a
feature not a bug. So for example, we're
talking about pain. For some women
they're taking the pill because of pain,
perhaps related to endometriosis. So
having lower estrogen activity of the
uterus is actually a great thing and for
many women having a 2-3 day
menses, or 1-2 day menses,
might be preferable to having a heavy
4-7 day flow. So there's value
to it for some, but you have to
acknowledge that those women who are
having lighter mensies are having less
estrogenic activity to the uterus while
they're taking the pill.
Right. That does totally make sense. Do you see the same outcomes when we are
comparing different forms of
contraception, like IUD, NuvaRing, birth
control pill? I'm sure a lot of my
followers are going to wonder if one is
more safe than the others when it comes
to fertility.
so there's I don't have
specific studies to reference when I'm
talking about the safety of each of
those three things, it just comes down to personal
experience.
I think the NuvaRing is effectively a
little bit more anti-estrogenic than the birth
control pill and the IUD is
different for everybody, but for most,
most women will have very light or no
menses indeed.
Okay. So is that a good
indicator of the estrogenic activity?
Yes it is.
Okay good to know. And why may
some women be affected by the pill but
others can go on the pill, go off the
pill and then they conceived like the next month?
Right? In fact, for some women
it actually enhances the chances
conception. Why do I keep
bringing up endometriosis? But women
with endometriosis, it's a disease
where the estrogen really
inflames the condition. It can even lead
to blocked or compromised fallopian
tubes, maybe even compromised
implantation more than on the pill. It
takes a lot of that activity away. Perhaps
their best chances for pregnancy fall
immediately the month after stopping
the pill when their cycles come back.
Some women with polycystic ovaries, that
means they have so many eggs that don't
ovulate regularly, they're on the pill
nice regular cycles. Sometimes they stop
the pill just for a couple months to
actually get some regular cycles. There
are definitely people out there who
really the moment they stop the pill do
achieve pregnancy. So if that's what they want, thats a good thing. They just have to be careful.
And what would be your advice
for women who are on some kind of
contraceptive and may want to get
pregnant too soon, maybe after this whole
covid thing. When should they plan to get
off of that contraceptive?
So the good news is for many women they're gonna
stop the pill and be able to get
pregnant right away. There's a subset of
women who won't have that experience
though. Which would be unnerving if that
was their goal to be able to achieve
pregnancy. They can know that's happening
to them if they stopped the pill and
nothing happens.
So what do I mean by "nothing happens"?
So some women, they just don't ovulate for a little while. That's actually relatively
common. How can you know if you're
ovulating? A couple of different ways. You
could use an app, like for example, lots
of good brands out there. Another thing
a person could do is follow those sticks at home, those LH
detection kits. So Clear Blue and even the
dollar store varieties. Just pee on a
stick every couple of days. Cheaper
sticks might be better because the money
starts to bug you after a while. But the
point is,  you'll get a little
surge that tells you that you're
ovulating and just after a person stops
the pill. For some women, it does take a
little while for that moment to kick in.
So it's not inherently problematic for
one or even two months of no regular
ovulation after stoping the pill. If it's
been more than one or two months though,
there's an
issue. It's called post-pill amenorrhea.
The pharma companies don't really
endorse the concept, they don't
think it's really real. Most physicians
do. It's hard to say in an individual's
case, if it's just exposing this
individuals underlying tendency to not
ovulate or for the secondary to the birth control pill.
Yeah there is so many confounders
there.
Yeah, so many confounders. But it might be reasonable if someone is looking to achieve pregnancy, to
predate stopping the pill by a month
or two. Maybe a little earlier than they
had thought they wanted to actually
conceive.
That makes sense. And is there anything that women can do to get their
cycle back quicker once they come off
birth controls or is there anything that
we can kind of incorporate into our lifestyle?
So there's a lot of things
that can be related to not having a
cycle when you're off the pill that
actually didn't have anything to do with the pill.
It might just be exposing an
underlying tendency. So it's very
reasonable to look at lifestyle. We are
in a time of great stress right now.
Stress is absolutely associated with
amenorrhea. If you're not ovulating
regularly, it might be because of some
some serious impacts that are happening
in your life at that moment. It's very
situational. You might decide that you
need to look for some online counseling
or other help but it might also be a
reasonable reaction to a temporary
situation.
Other people are struggling with sleep
for the same reasons. Sometimes people's
cycles they start to become
irregular because of other hormone
imbalances. Like
hypothyroid, for example. It's relatively
easy to test that, you might be able to
do a virtual consult with your family
doctor, go to a community lab
with a mask on and get a blood test
just to make sure your thyroid is in balance. Another thing it can be is just
around a person's own individual
lifestyle. Look at us all stuck at
home right now. Some of us might be
exercising too much. I suspect a lot of
us are not exercising enough. And some of
us, because of stress,
might be stress not-eating, that's not
everybody. A lot of people stress eating.
So weight can make a real
difference to this, both being
underweight very clear if your BMI is
less than 17.5 but also being
overweight. No it's not true for
everybody, as BMI increases that doesn't
inevitably mean that your cycle will get
irregular. If you are overweight right
now, that doesn't mean that just because
you lose weight your cycle is going to
become regular. But if you go to a doctor
one of the first things they're gonna
say is, if you can control your lifestyle
to control your weight into a into a
reassuring range and you'll be more
likely to ovulate regularly. For many
women they might be able to
individualize that they might be able to
look back at a time in life when they
were ovulating regularly and try to make
sure that that's the weight that they're at
right now. That's the amount of exercise
that they are doing right now. Maybe that's
the way to personalize your your
lifestyle to know that you've done the
right thing or for you, for your body,
because everyone's different.
Absolutely. Okay I
think that is fantastic advice for so
many women who are watching. So thank you so much Dr. Hannam. I, of course, will be
leaving links below to the Hannam website
if anyone's interested in getting some
more information on fertility treatments
from one of the top fertility clinics, as
far as I'm concerned.
Thank you very
kind of you to say and and for anybody
who's been watching this far, what
they might realize what they want more
than anything, is lifestyle
even dietary advice. I'm not going to
claim to be the best person for that, but
we work with some really great naturopaths
[inaudible]
but that's the type of thing that can really
help, especially during this time while
we're all stuck at home. You can get some
individualized advice so
you're not just doing a deep dive down
internet, that's that's a tough place for
anybody.
I agree. Okay thank you again so much, have a great day.
So nice to see you again.
- You too.
Thank you again to Dr. Hannam. I will definitely be leaving some
links below to Hannah's website if
you're interested in some more
information on fertility treatments from
one of the top fertility clinics. Now, I
also want to loop in a fellow
evidence-based health YouTuber, Mama Dr.
Jones.
So Dr. Jones, thank you so much for
joining me.
Thank you, I'm happy to be here and chat with you guys.
So as an OBGYN, how long would you
encourage women to wait after they do
come off of some kind of birth control
before they start worrying about needing
to see a fertility specialist, if they're
not getting their period back?
We do know
that the average time to resume having
periods after coming off the birth
control pill is right at a month, but
that means that some people resume
periods sooner than that, and some people
take a lot longer. So 90 days is probably
the top limit of where I would say
"I need you to call me and let me know if
we haven't started a period by this
point, so that we can look into it". As far
as when should you see a fertility
specialist, you know I think it kind of
depends on your OBGYN. I personally do a
good amount of infertility evaluation
and treatment, and a lot of generalist
OBGYNs do that. So I would prefer, for my
patients, to come in and see me so that
we can kind of start that initial workup
and then if it's something that we can't
take care of in my clinic, then we'll
send you on to an infertility specialist.
Okay that makes amazing sense and I
think that's really helpful
information for a lot of women who are
just unsure.
People know before they went
on birth control pills that their
periods were very irregular, and they
went on birth control pills to have a
little bit more predictability in their
cycles. I would tell that patient "you
should expect your periods to go back to
being irregular when you get off of your
birth control pill, I still want you to
be in communication with me if that
happens but it won't be surprising".
Yeah, that's a really good point because I
think the birth control pill can
mask a lot of these kinds of
irregularities when it comes to ones
cycle, so it's good to be aware that
it's not necessarily because of the pill
it's because maybe something was already
present before you went on the pill so
that's a really good point, as well.
Now, do you ever hear concerns from any
of your patients in your clinic about
using the birth control pill and having
fertility issues down the road?
Yeah I
think that that's a really common
question and concern that people have.
And, for me, the easiest way to explain it
is that a single percentage of the
population is going to have infertility
issues when they go to attempt pregnancy.
When we look at people who have been
on a birth control pill, you have what we
call "recall bias", you want to have
something to blame it on. And when you
come off the pill and you have
infertility that ends up requiring
treatment, it's really convenient if we
can say "oh the birth control pill caused
that". Unfortunately, what we see is that
it's not usually that easy and we don't
always know what causes it. But if you
look at groups of people who've been on
birth control pills and who've never
been on birth control pills, the risk of
infertility between those two groups
is very similar if not exactly the same. And so, this amongst hundreds of other
studies is the reason that we say it
does not affect your long-term fertility.
It is true to say that you may have a
delay and return to ovulation and, like
we just talked about, for most people
that's about a month for some people it
can be up to three months, but it
shouldn't cause actual infertility it
may just be that you need to come off...
but I usually counsel my patients "Come
off your birth control pill when, if you
got pregnant the month you came off it
would be okay but not when you have to
get pregnant the month you come off give
yourself some time and some flexibility"
because we can't always plan these things.
No, even if there is no issues
with the birth control pill it can
take women many months and many cycles
to conceive. So it's always good to plan
for a little buffer in there so yeah
that's really good advice. Now, of course,
I want to make it clear that I am all
for reproductive choice and options, but
in your experience, are some birth
control methods less likely to cause
this delay in, you know, getting that
cycle back in the ovulation or is it
highly individual? So I'm talking about
like you know the pill versus IUDs
versus NuvaRings. All those kinds
of different options.
So it's going to be
very individual between the types.
Obviously if you're not on something
that is hormonal then you shouldn't have
that delay, so if you're only using
natural family planning or you're only
using condoms then you shouldn't
experience that. But anything you're
using that affects your hormones or that
includes hormones, and even sometimes the
copper IUD as well, you're going to see
that in some people it has no effect and
then some people it has delayed
ovulation affects. As far as pill versus
patch versus NuvaRing, these three are
all the same medication just in a
different delivery form. So those 3
should be really similar amongst people,
you know, how you as an individual react
to it should be the same between those
three. For the Depo-Provera shot, this can
be much more unpredictable. And
resumption of ovulation when you've been
on the shot can be extremely long time.
So if someone comes in and says you know
"I don't wanna get pregnant this year but
I think we're gonna start trying you
know March of next year". I usually would
recommend to them "Let's not do the Depo
shot because it may be that you have
really delayed intervals to achieving
pregnancy with that option". For the IUD, I would
usually tell people to have it taken out
kind of the same as the pill, you know,
give yourself six months to go back to
normal periods but know that there's a
really good chance you'll be in the
majority of people who are able to get
pregnant far earlier than six months out.
Yeah that's really good advice. So you
know, surprises can happen so just be
ready for that I suppose.
Absolutely.
And is there a specific product that you
and your practice kind of gravitate
towards most when it comes to all of
those different options?
As far as what
type of birth control I recommend?
Yeah.
People always ask me, I think the most
common question when someone comes in to
talk about birth control with me is
"What's the best one, what do you
recommend" and I have none. I
have a chart, I think I've
gone through it on my channel at one
point that comes from bedsider.org.
It goes over all of the pregnancy risks
and different tiers of birth control
from over-the-counter options, to
pills, patches, rings, shots, to IUDs and
Nexplanon. I dont think theres a better or worse option.
I think it's very individual.
So, like I was saying, if you think a year
down the road you may want to try to get
pregnant then Depo-Provera  may not
be the best option. But if you think it's
gonna be three or five years and you
want to use the Depo shot, I think
that's a really great option for some
people.
Amazing. Well thank you so much
for all of your incredible insight and
your amazing content. If you're not
already following Mama Dr. Jones,
everyone you've gotta hit up this
channel. I think if you are a fan of my
kind of evidence-based content, you're
going to love this amazing content.
Especially as it pertains to women's
health. So I'm gonna leave some links
below to her channel. So thank you again
for joining us.
Thank you so much
Thank you, thank you, Mama Dr. Jones. Of course, if
you're not already following this woman
you definitely need to. I think if you
love my evidence-based approach you are
going to love hers, as well. Especially as
it pertains to women's health. So of
course, I'm going to leave some links
below to her channel and definitely
you're gonna want to subscribe. Now
bottom line folks, it's difficult to
pinpoint an exact cause of infertility
post-pill. Again, there still needs to be
further more extensive research done to
explain why some women struggle to get
pregnant after coming off the pill, while
others can just have sex the first month
and get pregnant. Until then, my
recommendation is to speak to your
doctor about getting a referral to a
fertility clinic as soon as you feel
that you might be struggling. The sooner
that you can get some answers, the sooner
that you can get an action plan in place
to help you conceive in good time. Well
folks, that is all for me today. If you
like this video please be sure to give
it the thumbs up, leave me a comment
below with your experience with the pill
or really any questions that you may
want me to cover and investigate as part
of this Fertility Files series. Subscribe
to the channel and I will see you next
time on Abbey's Kitchen. Bye!